(indie rock music)
(tires crumble through dirt and rock)
- [Voiceover] Every year
the world's most elite
mountain bikers gather in France
for a race unlike any other.
(exhales and speaks in foreign language)
(indie rock music)
- It's the longest
downhill race in the world.
(indie rock music)
- [Voiceover] That's right.
Megavalanche is the longest
downhill race in the world.
18 miles long, 10,000 feet
high in the French Alps
and a crazy starting line of 3,000
cyclists on a mountain peak.
This is Remy Absalon.
He won the Megavalanche.
- I start mountain bike when I was young
and your own mountain bike is really cool
because we can explore
all around the world.
Megavalanche Alpe d'Huez
takes place in the French Alps
in Alpe d'Huez so not so far
of Italy and Switzerland.
It's really high in the Alps so you have a
very good view, 360 degrees around you.
(indie rock music)
It's really crazy, I
don't know why I do that.
(rock music and slow hand clapping)
You ride all kind of terrain.
First the glacier and after
the rocky sections, the forest.
(indie rock music)
It's really physical with some happiness.
So when you cross the
line and you are first,
you are really happy and
you want to try again.
(indie rock music)